>>Hi YouTube my name is Dan Shapiro. I direct
the Harvard International Negotiation Initiative.
And it's a wonderful experience being here
at Davos, and it's a wonderful experience
to have the opportunity to talk with you today,
and hear your feedback as well. The work I
do is as a negotiation of conflict resolution
and what is the one issue that I see as most
important in 2008. Well there's plenty of
them. The one I'm particularly focused on
is how to deal the emotional and identity
based dimension of conflict. Looking around
the world right now as our world is shrinking.
It's getting flatter, and more globalized.
People are interacting more and more and that
makes it more and more challenging to get
work effectively done. And ultimately what
that means is that emotions are become a potential
trouble point, but at the same time it can
be one of your greatest assets. In 2008 what
can we be most focused on? I would suggest
we focus on the human dimension of conflict
and of human interaction. So for example,
as you are interacting with other people in
this upcoming year. In what ways do you try
to appreciate their perspective even if you
strongly disagree with their perspectives.
Simply by appreciating, the research is quite
clear on this. You are able to enlist helpful
emotions, and you and the other party will
are going to be able get along much more effectively,
whether you are a head of state trying to
negotiate a big peace treaty, or whether you
are like myself trying to negotiate with my
wife where to go on Friday night for dinner.
So good luck with all of your negotiations,
and pay particular attention to the emotional
dimension. And if you're interested in more
information my colleague Roger Fisher and
I recently wrote a new book on that subject
called Beyond Reason, using emotions as you
negotiate. And I also direct an initiative.
You can check out our initiative at our website
just Google: Havard International Negotiation
Initiative. You'll find us. I look forward
to your feedback and to thinking through your
ideas and talking to you over YouTube. Thank
so much.